[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous pendant
cette première demi-heure sénateur
communiste du Nord vice-président de la
commission des finances on va bien sûr
longuement parler du budget tout à
l'heure puisque vous avez débuté hier
son examen mais d'abord un bout de foot
et pas que vous puisque s'ouvre la Coupe
du Monde au Qatar dimanche qui n'est pas
que sportive un choix qui pose question
ce choix du Qatar tente sur le plan des
droits de l'homme que sur le plan de
l'écologie hier Emmanuel Macron a dit
qu'il ne fallait pas politiser le sport
et que ces questions là il fallait se
les poser avant vous êtes d'accord avec
ça il aurait fallu se les poser avant
oui bien sûr difficile de parler de
boycott maintenant mais franchement
c'est cette Coupe du Monde qui devrait
être un moment de joie de partage de
fait avec toutes les nations du monde
c'est un non-sens absolu quoi d'abord
les conditions d'attribution de cette
compétition au Qatar je sais que la
justice travaille sur le sujet il faudra
suivre le prêt les les conclusions un
non-sens écologique qu'on soit des
stades climatisés voilà le calendrier on
interrompt les championnats nationaux
européens essentiellement pour permettre
de cette compétition la question des
droits de l'homme évidemment
des droits humains les 6500 travailleurs
népalais notamment entre autres qui sont
morts dans ces chantiers et sans
régulation enfin franchement
choquant inadmissible il faut vraiment
c'était la question d'actualité qu'on a
posé cette semaine au gouvernement
là-dessus et imaginer une agence
internationale à l'avenir pour éviter ce
genre de décision pour assurer une un
bon choix en matière d'attribution des
grandes compétitions sportives et un
suivi de l'organisation pendant les
années jusqu'à l'événement en question
parce que c'est tout à fait inacceptable
et cette Coupe du Monde au Qatar mais
tout le monde mal à l'aise vous dites
trop tard pour un balcon sportif mais
est-ce que Emmanuel Macron qui a promis
d'aller soutenir les Bleus s'ils
arrivaient au stade des demi-finales
est-ce qu'il a raison d'y aller pour
vous il pourrait y aller pour passer un
message fort une conférence de presse
une déclaration en même temps que de
participer à cette Coupe du Monde
franchement il faut qu'il arrive avec
des bagages et un message très fort à
l'internation presqu'île de la dire pour
vous condamné condamner ce choix
condamner les avoir une pensée pour ses
victimes ces 6500 travailleurs morts sur
les chantiers le non-respect des droits
pour les les transgenres les lesbiens
les Les Gets etc tout cela est combattu
dans ce pays voilà il faut qu'il
s'exprime là dessus il faut que ça voit
uniquement pour supporter il doit y
aller avec un message politique
indispensable vous le dites cette Coupe
du Monde c'est aussi normalement un
moment de communion nationale il y a des
maires qui ont pris la décision de ne
pas organiser de Fan Zone de ne pas
mettre des congés en dans leur commune
vous voulez comprenez c'est est-ce que
c'est pas punir les Français d'un choix
dont ils ne sont pas responsables
écoutez des gens qui souhaitent regarder
regarderont sur les chaînes qui
retransmettent après qu'une collectivité
organise une un événement collectif ça a
été des moments formidables en 98 j'ai
se souvenir dans ma commune de Nando ça
s'est fait partout c'était un moment de
communion mais là dans ces conditions là
franchement le cœur n'y est pas quoi
donc je comprends qui reculent qui
refusent de de d'organiser des visions
collectives des matchs dans les dans les
salles etc un peu d'hypocrisie de
certains maires notamment peut-être la
mère de Paris qui est qui affiche son
soutien au PSG financé par le Qatar et
qui dans le même temps ne met pas des
grands géants pour cette coupe du monde
ça fait partie des contradictions c'est
à elle de les gérer voilà en tout cas
que les maires n'organisent pas les
diffusions collectives j'approuve
complètement on va parler de l'actualité
du Sénat actualité chargée puisque vous
avez entamé hier l'examen du budget un
marathon budgétaire on va voir les temps
forts de ces premières heures de séances
avec Quentin calmé
[Musique]
Jean Quentin bonjour Oriane bonjour Eric
Bocquet et Quentin vous avez suivi
attention l'examen de ce budget les
premières heures de cette séance le
gouvernement qui parle d'un budget de
protection des Français oui c'est ça
vous l'avez dit en titre d'ailleurs
notamment face à la hausse de
l'inflation bien sûr en particulier des
cours de l'énergie l'idée va être de
mieux cibler les aides dans les de
répondre je cite Gabriel Attal un climat
d'inquiétude qui est réel écouté hier à
la tribune le ministre du Budget
protéger les Français ce n'est pas se
satisfaire d'une politique du chèque ou
d'une vision court termeiste c'est
assumer qu'il faut à la fois répondre
aux urgences du quotidien financer
l'action publique préparer l'avenir et
protéger nos comptes c'est au tour de
ces quatre axes que s'articule notre
action il n'y a pas à choisir parmi ces
objectifs même s'ils peuvent parfois
sembler paradoxaux contradictoires car
la réalité c'est qu'il faut tous les
mener de front alors dans le même temps
le gouvernement en tant protégé
également les entreprises en baissant
les impôts de production et aussi en
soutenant les PME nous ne laisserons
tomber aucun site industriel français à
dibrine Lemaire écouter le ministre de
l'économie à la tribune je veux donc le
dire avec beaucoup de force face à la
crise énergétique les entreprises
françaises seront aussi bien défendus
aussi bien protégés que les entreprises
allemandes je rappelle d'ailleurs à ceux
qui l'auraient oublié que pour la moitié
de leurs factures et les la police
française continue de bénéficier d'une
électricité nucléaire à bas coût à
travers la reine qui est un avantage
compétitif significatif alors il y a
pendant la séance on entend que la
droite sénatoriale se montrait assez
critique sur ce budget notamment sur le
niveau d'endettement de la France Bruno
Retailleau dans les précédents jours
avait déjà fustigé des hypothèses
économiques qui surestimentent les
recettes et les dépenses qui galopent et
bien hier on a entendu sur le même ton
le rapporteur général à l'air du budget
c'est Jean-François Husson écoutait le
déficit de l'État supérieur en 2023 à
150 milliards d'euros pour la quatrième
année consécutive je le rappelle ne
redescend plus du pic atteint depuis la
crise sanitaire c'est un budget de
l'État qui est en fait et je le redis
celui de tous les records jamais un
projet de loi de finance n'avait été
présenté avec un tel niveau de déficit
dès le début de la discussion budgétaire
jamais un budget n'avait prévu un tel
niveau d'emprunt nouveau à hauteur de
270 milliards d'euros 2023 jamais non
plus la France n'a dû rembourser autant
d'emprunts arrivés à l'échéance
156,5 milliards d'euros voilà il y a
c'était donc la première journée à la
discussion générale c'est comme ça qu'on
l'entame ce débat ça va durer comme ça
jusqu'au aussi décembre au Sénat et on
verra ce que la droite et le centre vote
et comment est-ce qu'ils amorent le
texte et après on verra encore une autre
question c'est qu'est-ce que le
gouvernement conservera dans les
modifications de la chambre haute
puisque tout se débat se fait contexte
de l'utilisation du 49-3 par le
gouvernement à l'Assemblée nationale
d'ailleurs les communistes vous avez
déposé une motion vous avez comme cela
condamné est-ce que c'était passé à
l'Assemblée nationale et vous-même Eric
Bocquet vous avez dit condamné cette
méthode en disant le Parlement doit se
défendre contre l'une des deux chambres
et piétiner et vous avez demandé
également qu'elles étaient les garanties
que le gouvernement pouvait apporter au
sénateur sur ce qui serait conservé dans
le texte vous vous dénoncez la méthode
qui employée par le Gouvernement sur ce
texte et complètement d'ailleurs j'ai
fait référence à une interview de
Gabriel Attal le 26 septembre dernier
dans la gazette.fr où il expliquait la
nécessité que les collectivités
participaient aussi au redressement des
comptes publics donc
limiter vos dépenses alors que les
besoins sont gigantesques mais il le
fait d'une manière très macronienne
verticale c'est pas brutal mais il parle
d'incitation au départ et qu'en cas de
refus avéré des collectivités de réduire
leurs dépenses on pourrait aller jusqu'à
des reprises et des refuses dotation
c'est grave quoi c'est une atteinte à
l'article 72 de la Constitution libre
des collectivités on va reparler des
collectivités locales on va revenir sur
le fond mais sur la méthode pour vous le
examen de ce budget n'aurait pas dû
aller jusqu'au bout parce que vous
demandiez hier oui c'est un peu ce qu'on
demandait mais en fait on a surtout
dénoncé l'utilisation du 49-3 à
l'Assemblée nationale voilà donc le
débat nous on est toujours favorable au
débat mais on peut contradictoire de
dire il y a 49-3 il y a pas de déballage
assemblation nationale et en même temps
de faire une
motions en septembre on sait pas trop ce
que c'est ça n'a pas abouti à grand
chose et puis derrière on a le 49.3 et
les injonctions
verticales du monsieur Gabriel Attal
ministre des comptes publics à l'endroit
des collectivités pour resserrer les
boulons il y a tout le disque
de toute façon
chaque groupe aura des propositions
apportées à défendre c'est un c'est une
tribune aussi on s'adresse à la nation
sur le fond quoi oui que dire de
l'équilibre général du texte parce que
on voit que la gauche des noms dénonce
toutes les aides aux entreprises on l'a
entendu encore à la tribune hier la
droite parle de dépenses hors normes le
gouvernement est comme ça pris entre
entre deux feux comment comprendre ce
paradoxe nous ce qu'on dénonce c'est les
aides sans conditionnement sans contrôle
160 milliards d'euros chaque année
versés au monde économique aux
entreprises on se demande parfois où
l'assistana se trouve que certains
dénoncent par ailleurs un budget avec
345 milliards d'euros de recettes
fiscales 270 milliards d'euros d'emprunt
nouveau on a emprunté 267 années autant
l'année dernière voilà donc on se paye
avec la dette et la dette c'est nous
tous qui allons la payer et c'est
l'argument majeur pour imposer
l'austérité aux collectivités aux
entreprises et aux particuliers c'est là
la contradiction que l'on veut dénoncer
quand un sur la question des
collectivités justement oui alors c'est
vrai que ça a été l'un des points sur
lesquels gauche et droite vous vous êtes
entendus pour dénoncer le texte du
Gouvernement car et bien et ce qui était
au coeur des reproches des sénateurs ce
sont ces contraints de confiance il
s'agit pour le gouvernement d'encadrer
la hausse des dépenses des collectivités
locales ces vécues comme un retour des
contrats de Cahors qui avaient été mis
en place entre 2018 et 2020 et c'était
vécu déjà à l'époque comme une forme de
recentralisation avec des préfets qui
pouvaient comme cela donner leur avis
contraindre les budgets des
collectivités locales à tous les
échelons des strates de la du maillage
local on écoute à ce sujet la sénatrice
LR Christine lavard dans les revient
juste après le retour des contrats de
confiance est une véritable provocation
ma dernière question gouvernement n'a
obtenu aucune réponse sur mes deux
interrogations comment osez-vous et
surtout vous engagez vous à respecter le
vote des deux chambres qui part deux
fois ont rejeté le dispositif pour le
ministre Béchu qui m'a répondu
je le cite cette manière de faire est
une façon de reprovoquer le dialogue
enfin franchement moi je pense que c'est
plutôt une façon de reprovoquer tout
court on comprend donc aucune des deux
Chambres du Parlement ne voulait de se
voler du texte sur les contrats de
confiance et le ce volet revient via le
49-3 donc la droite crie au scandale
vous êtes d'accord sur cette position
écoutez il suffit de voir les réactions
de toutes les associations depuis que le
budget était présenté fin septembre j'en
ai vu aucune qui approuve ces décisions
de contraindre et limiter les dépenses
et collectivités les besoins sont
gigantesques je l'ai dit hier dans mon
intervention les collectivités c'est 70%
de l'investissement public dans ce pays
c'est 8% de la dette nationale stable
depuis 30 ans et c'est 0% de déficit
public qui peut faire mieux que ça
franchement donc s'attaquer aux
collectivités c'est style une balle dans
le pied pour redynamiser les territoires
économie de l'emploi et le développement
sur ces contrats hier Christophe Béchu
le ministre de la cohésion des
territoires était notre invité il a dit
qu'il était ouvert avec un dialogue au
Sénat effectivement il est reconnaît que
via le 49-3 c'est contrats étaient
revenus de manière plus dure que ce qui
avait été négocié avec les collectivités
ça vous rend optimiste si c'est ouvert
au Sénat soit on verra mais si ça repart
à l'Assemblée qu'on réapplique le 49-3
l'affaire sera plie on en parlera plus
quoi si on comment comprendre ses
contrats de confiance c'est des gages
que donne la France aussi à l'Union
européenne c'est absolument c'est
exactement ça on est engagé là dans un
plan 2022-2027 avec des engagements par
rapport à nos partenaires européens
selon le mot et donc il y a des
engagements effectivement de réduire la
dépense publique ça vient de là c'est le
traité de Lisbonne c'est Maastricht
voilà pur jus qu'on va ré-appliquer on
est dans ce cadre contraint là
effectivement donc on veut donner des
gages à la Commission et et on fait
payer les collectivités ce qui est une
erreur économique politique et même
sociale dit qu'il y a une augmentation
de la dotation globale de fonctionnement
de 320 millions d'euros dans ce budget
c'est inédit depuis 13 ans c'est ce
qu'ils disent vous connaissez quand même
que le gouvernement soutient ces
collectivités
on commence à voir les informations sur
et le filet de sécurité qui a été décidé
pour par rapport aux dépenses d'énergie
des collectivités j'ai vu les
répartitions pour l'instant les acomptes
versés dans ma région des
Hauts-de-France huit communes c'est 652
dans le Nord ont été reconnus zéro dans
le Pas-de-Calais 0 dans la Somme 113
dans l'Oise curieusement pourquoi
curieusement pourquoi l'Oise ou alors
ils ont des communes très pauvres où
elles sont très mal gérées mais pourquoi
113 dans l'Oise et zéro dans le
Pas-de-Calais moi j'ai des noms de
communes à donner
qui aussi peut aiguillé s'effon vous
pensez je m'interroge sur cette
différence 113 angloise zéro dans le
Pas-de-Calais il y a un sujet voilà je
pose la question
sur les un dernier mot sur les
collectivités puisqu'il y a aussi un
débat autour de la CV cotisation sur la
valeur ajoutée des entreprises la droite
ça suppression le gouvernement aussi
Gérard Larcher il dit qu'il faut se
donner un nom pour mettre en oeuvre
cette suppression c'est le bon compromis
pour vous c'est toutes les
contradictions de la droite quoi c'est
sur le fond il y a pas grand chose qui
distingue la majorité du Sénat de la
politique menée par Monsieur Macron ils
sont d'accord à 96 97%. mais en même
temps il faut qu'ils apparaissent comme
les meilleurs opposants pour la suite
pour demain pour la prochaine également
donc je pense qu'ils sont en
contradiction ils sont un petit rayées
entre les deux voilà non la CVAE c'est 8
milliards en moins pour les
collectivités à nouveau après la
suppression de la TP il y a 12 ans la
taxe d'habitation etc c'est de moins en
moins de moyens donc oui alors on nous
dit la DGF augmente un peu mais dans le
même temps on nous retire 9 milliards
d'euros c'est énorme on va encore
réduire les capacités d'intervention des
collectivités il y a une autre question
qui divise la majorité c'est naturel
pour le coup la question des super
profits puisque de la taxation des super
profils les républicains sont en compte
les centrées sont pour vous êtes pour
évidemment la taxation de ces super
profil vous espérez la faire passer avec
la pluie décentrée
des centristes sur ce sujet de sa
revient je le mets auraient souhaité que
le débat soit enterré le 12 août c'est
il en est rien dans ça revient avec
force regardez les bilans de dividendes
enfin c'est tous les jours ça s'étale au
grand jour donc c'est de plus en plus
justifié donc le débat reviendra est-ce
que ça passera j'en sais rien parce que
j'ai l'impression de voir la coulisse ça
discute beaucoup ça et c'est de dealer
ça dit ça téléphone voilà ça s'est passé
comme ça au mois d'août donc là
attendons mais en tout cas nous on
soutiendra cette démarche là d'où elles
viennent et pourquoi pas un vote
majoritaire au Sénat ça marcherait
comment est-ce que vous placez la barre
sur ces super profits c'est quoi les
Allemands que vous pousserez vous bah
nous c'est à l'ensemble des potes pas de
manière ciblée à l'ensemble des grands
entreprises de CAC 40 notamment les les
entreprises de énergéticiennes les les
gaziers les entrepr qui ont sur profité
justement de la crise énergétique c'est
pas de les cibler on peut parler aussi
de de l'industrie pharmaceutique les CMA
CGM les conteneurs ont explosé
totale énergie engie voilà tous ces
gens-là ont profité de fait
objectivement de cette crise vous avez
parlé hier dans votre discours lors de
l'examen de ce budget du climat social
vous redoutez une explosion sociale
le pays va mal quoi on va pas jouer les
pleureuses on n'est pas germinal mais
quand même hier le Secours Catholique a
publié son son rapport annuel sur la
pauvreté on va en parler donc on voit
les chiffres voilà ça c'est la réalité
quotidienne c'est ce qu'on entend dans
nos auditions là quand on prépare le
rapport budgétaire sur le la mission
dont j'ai la charge avec Arnaud Bazin on
entend tout ça on le vit on ça s'exprime
il y a ça bouillonne quoi on en parle
tout de suite avec la presse régionale
le temps de remercier Quentin tout à
l'heure dans le club on va reparler de
la fin de la Coop exactement et des
républicains peut-être aussi quelques
contradictions sur l'écologie
tout à l'heure avec Quentin bien
évidemment on va parler justement de de
ces questions de pouvoir d'achat et et
des associations évidemment avec la
presse régionale on va au Puy-en-Velay
on retrouve Christian Christophe down
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
Christophe rédacteur en chef de l'éveil
de la Haute-Loire et il y a quelques
jours justement vous êtes partis en
immersion avec une équipe du Secours
populaire
oui Oriane et avec l'inflation et la
flambée de l'énergie et bien le nombre
de demandeurs de l'aide adelimentaire
étant très forte hausse ils sont environ
20% de plus depuis septembre et les
bénévoles de l'association nous disent
clairement que les besoins devraient
encore augmenter d'ici la fin de l'année
alors on y retrouve des retraités des
familles monoparentales mais aussi
beaucoup de travailleurs qui n'arrivent
plus à s'en sortir ceux que ce cours
populaire on appelle maintenant les
nouveaux pauvres alors ma question Eric
Bocquet c'est face à cette situation qui
semble s'aggraver dans le pays quel
pourrait être selon vous les leviers
pour tenter d'endiguer cette précarité
galopante la question du pouvoir d'achat
se pose parce que dans les personnes qui
fréquentent les permanences jusqu'au
populaire du square catholique des
Restaurants du Coeur on les a tous
rencontrés il n'y a pas que des gens
privés d'emploi il y a des femmes
salariées seules il y a des retraités
pauvres il y a des salariés à temps
complet dans les revenus ne suffisent
plus à faire face aux dépenses de loyer
et d'énergie etc
c'est une question de partage de la
richesse jamais la question de se poser
avec autant de force donc la taxation du
super profit c'est pas pour faire joli
c'est pas un gadget de gauche c'est pour
répondre à ces situations d'urgence là
que vous que vous détaillez face à cette
question de la vie chère Fabien Roussel
appelle les salariés à s'unir et à se
retrouver sur les ronds-points est-ce
que 4 ans après les gilets jaunes et
dans le climat social que vous décrivez
c'est pas un peu souffler sur les
braises écoutez le mécontentement est là
vous savez le le grand mouvement ne se
décrète pas on n'appuie pas sur un
bouton en mai 68 on n'a pas appuyé sur
un bouton les gens ont estimé que ça
suffisait qu'il fallait vivre mieux ils
se sont mobilisés ils l'ont décidé des
millions de gens voilà moi je pense
qu'il y a besoin d'union c'est clair
faut que tout le monde se rassemble
parce qu'on est tous confrontés à la
même chose en face de nous enfin quand
on voit
quel que soit la forme moi je j'appelle
pas la violence j'appelle à la
mobilisation à la réaction parce que il
faut se rendre compte qu'aujourd'hui on
sent bien que ça bouillonne il y a du
sacrogne il y a du mécontentement mais
il y a aussi pas mal de résignation en
gros les gens ne croient pas qu'il y a
une alternative nous sommes convaincus
avec d'autres qu'il y a une alternative
à cette société qui crée beaucoup de
richesses et qui la partagent de moins
en moins ça peut pas durer comme ça ça
peut pas durer comme ça donc toutes les
formes d'action toutes les mobilisations
sur le fond et pas de manière
anecdotique mais sur le fond le fond du
partage de la richesse sont son
souhaitable effectivement autrement on
va pas en sortir on glisse vers le pire
y compris au plan politique vous voyez
ce qui se passe en Europe en Italie en
Pologne en Hongrie on voit surgir des
régimes un peu inquiétants autoritaires
progressiste de manière urgente dans les
années qui viennent je n'exclut pas du
tout le risque que le pire puisse
survenir
on va parler d'un autre sujet Christophe
avec vous on retourne au Puy-en-Velay et
c'est votre dossier spécial aujourd'hui
à la Une de l'éveil de la Haute-Loire
c'est la bataille de l'eau
oui en effet c'est la une du jour la
bataille de l'eau un dossier de six
pages alors comme d'autres départements
et bien la Haute-Loire elle connaît une
année cette année une sécheresse
exceptionnelle et surtout qui s'éternise
le symbole de cette situation c'est le
cauchemar que vit depuis 5 mois la
petite commune du boucher Saint-Nicolas
ou nous étions mercredi en reportage
pour résumer le village n'a plus d'eau
depuis que sa source est tari et la
municipalité se bat aujourd'hui pour
trouver une solution
alors au-delà du simple constat des
réserves qui sont au plus bas on
s'intéresse aujourd'hui aux tensions qui
voient le jour entre les différents
usagers de l'eau les agriculteurs les
acteurs du tourisme les particuliers et
les collectivités et justement ces
collectivités aujourd'hui on les
encourage à refaire leur réseau d'eau
dans notre enquête on montre que 30% de
l'eau potable est perdue dans des fuites
rien que pour le département de la
Haute-Loire
alors à l'heure de la sobriété de la
préservation de cette ressource
naturelle est-ce que cela hérite boquée
devra se traduire forcément par une
augmentation du prix de l'eau pour le
consommateur non moi je pense qu'il faut
d'abord s'intéresser au profit réalisé
par les distributeurs privés de l'eau ou
cité effectivement les pourcentages
absolument effarants de pertes de
millions de mètres cubes d'eau ce que
vous dit dans la région de dans votre
région et valable également dans les
miennes donc il faut que distribuer
beaucoup moins aux actionnaires des
boîtes privées Veolia et d'autres pour
engager des arches des sommes
conséquentes pour remettre en état le
réseau pour si déjà on récupère 30 ou
40% des fuites constatées aujourd'hui on
va permettre effectivement de satisfaire
les besoins des agriculteurs les
particuliers et des industriels donc
c'est d'abord de l'investissement dans
le réseau avant de distribuer de
l'argent aux actionnaires
c'est aussi la question peut-être
Christophe vous pouvez en dire un mot
puisque dans votre dossier du jour il y
a une interview du sénateur le rendu
plomb sur la gestion de l'eau
qui lui aussi s'exprime notamment avec
sa casquette d'agriculteur puisque il
est il est aussi agriculteur et lui
évoque les solutions qui peuvent être
mis en place avec notamment des barrages
et des stockages aujourd'hui des retenus
colinaires qui sont quand même des
installations qui font aujourd'hui débat
dans le dans le paysage local il faut
réfléchir à cette question le rendu
plombier ce matin dans l'éveil de la
Haute-Loire qu'il faut relancer le
dossier des constructions de barrage
pourquoi pas il faut créer des réserves
naturelles d'eau là on est dans une
période où la pluie revient et c'est
bien mais ça peut durer encore quelques
mois parce qu'effectivement les déficits
sont considérables faut que les nappes
se reconstituent mais inventer les
solutions des retenues d'eau pluviales
créer des voilà dans le là où c'est
possible et en concertation avec les
populations concernées puisque ça fait
partie du débat est-ce que les bassines
pour les agriculteurs pour vous c'est
une solution envisageable peut-être j'ai
pas d'avis arrêté là-dessus en tout cas
il faut de la concertation de la
réflexion commune avec les élus les les
populations les enfin voilà mais tout le
monde autour de la table pour imaginer
les meilleures solutions qui qui les
nuisent à personne et qui préserve la
ressource en eau dans toutes les régions
quoi merci merci
à la Une de votre journal et on va
parler dans quelques secondes avec Eric
Orsenna de ce sujet de l'eau un mot pour
terminer sur votre partie
Eric Bocquet et Fabien Roussel Fabien
Roussel il est pas tout à fait d'accord
avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est un
euphémisme il est d'ailleurs le il n'a
pas voté la plupart des notions de
censure présentée par la France
insoumise est-ce que c'est une position
qui est partagée au sein de votre partie
où est-ce qu'il est isolé Fabien Roussel
au centre de tester
par un choix très majoritaire de notre
partie je ne regrette pas à titre
personnellement un instant ce choix je
crois que c'est partagé où c'est le
continue continue son tour de France là
il est reparti sur les routes de France
Pas-de-Calais Montargis dans Gironde
très bientôt pour rencontrer les gens
pas parler de tous les sujets sans
tabous c'est comme ça que cette campagne
s'intitule pour écouter les gens et puis
contribuer au rassemblement des forces
progressistes voilà des forces de gauche
oui il y a des nuances il y a des
différences c'est pas grave
ils font partie du paysage on exclut
personne le PS les écologistes font
partie du paysage une gauche affaiblie
aujourd'hui toute la gauche rassemblait
aujourd'hui n'est pas à 30% hein c'est
pas suffisant il faut que tout le monde
grandisse pour que tout le monde
grandisse pour avoir une gauche forte et
qui puisse construire un projet
alternatif dont je parlais tout à
l'heure dont on a besoin parce que si ça
ne vient pas le pire peut survenir
encore une fois j'y insiste en Italie ça
s'est produit on a eu bolsonaro au
Brésil on a eu Trump aux États-Unis
enfin vous voyez ce qui se passe dans le
monde on voit des régimes inquiétants
apparaît donc il est l'urgence d'une
alternative progressiste à gauche qui
met fin à ce libéralisme qui fait tant
de dégâts merci Eric merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin et
vous allez évidemment retourner en
séance puisque l'examen du budget se
poursuit merci d'avoir été